how have each of you changed the
character of kratos how do you think his
his arc has grown over the games i mean
i think it maybe it's a little bit to
our detriment perhaps we haven't evolved
his arc to change him as a person i mean
he still kind of just shouts at the gods
and says ares and athena a lot which is
great he's an ornery character but there
are layers beneath that that i think we
could have explored i know for myself i
felt like there was a lot of balls i
dropped because i tried maybe to go a
little bit wider i wanted to really have
kratos as impact be felt throughout all
of the world that's I think is an
exciting aspect about go Sparta is that
it really gets down to Kratos his heart
more of a personal story rather than
maybe the overreaching grand epic that I
was trying to go for it's easy to forget
that the God of War series began with a
quiet solemn moment of despair standing
atop a mountain Kratos laments being
abandoned by the gods and unable to find
hope he forfeits his life to end his
suffering like many characters from
Greek mythology Kratos began life as a
tragic figure manipulated by deceitful
gods into killing his own family then
promised respite from the torment only
to be denied it it was an impactful
moment of emotional vulnerability for
god of War's protagonist but it was a
rare one
at its core God of War games were about
fulfilling a power fantasy by empowering
players to carve a bloody path through
the pantheon of Greek deities the
opportunity for heartfelt moments of
emotion were few and far in between but
for Corey Borlaug writer of multiple God
of War titles and director of God of War
- Kratos is redemption is in those small
sparks of humanity after a few years
away from the series Balrog rejoined
developer Sony Santa Monica in 2013 and
began work on a reboot of the series
returning to the character he helped
define he set himself his very own
Herculean labor to humanize Kratos
[Music]
this franchise is a huge part of who I
am I didn't want to tan the way that it
ended I always saw it going into another
place I had kind of said like I I I
really feel like I have another one
Indian when I kind of went on that
walkabout the first thing I did was
right to go to work goes to sparta
script and then when I finished that one
I said well that wasn't the one more I
have any like I love that script but I
was like I have another one that's just
like going out there and just doing
something crazy but I just don't know
that's something crazy as we now know
was to relocate Kratos and the franchise
to the realm of the Norse gods which may
feel like an obvious next step for the
series
according to borlaug however the
decision to ship to Norse mythology
served to expose facets of Kratos his
character that were lost underneath or
the blood and sinew of the previous
games I didn't really want to go and
reboot to Greek mythology I wanted to
explore something else I think giving
him a new setting a fresh start was
important and changing craters are at
least exposing a different side to him
making him more dimensional kind of the
uncovering the ark archaeological
uncovering of his humanity to discover
there is a human buried way deep inside
right a human that was beat down right
not only I think by the horrible things
that happened in his family life but the
how he's trained in the new god of war
Kratos is very much outside of his
comfort zone not just because he's in
the realm of Thor Loki and Odin
disconnected from its culture history
and traditions but also because he's now
a single father his son at Reyes
represents something that both Kratos
and the God of War series have neglected
to explore responsibility for Balrog and
the team the key to humanizing Kratos a
larger-than-life antihero lies in this
father-and-son dynamic at Reyes is
unaware of his father's history but
eager to prove himself and seeing
flashes of the same red-hot temperament
Kratos knows that at Reyes is at risk of
repeating the sins of the father to
serve as a guiding hand for his son
Kratos needs to soften something which
is entirely in opposition of his nature
at the same time at Reyes is more
connected to the world around him having
been born and raised
they're for Kratos this means having the
humility to allow his son to guide him
he is this way to get greatest open up a
little bit more but also this sense of
like he actually has just as much to
teach as Kratos does in some ways more
right he's seeing the world as as a
human
he doesn't understand God's right he
understands what it was to be a him and
that's how he was raised and he's able
to help Kratos see that to pull a little
bit of that out of him so that this
little kid is teaching his demigod and
what it is to be a human well as down is
actually trying to teach him how not to
make the mistakes that he made
[Music]
now you are ready this dependency is
similar to the relationship between Joel
and Ellie in the loss of us
despite ostensibly being a game about
surviving the post apocalypse the loss
of us focuses on the relationship
between a cynical father figure and the
young innocent girl he takes
responsibility for like Joel Kratos is
hardened and in bed closed off to the
world and people around him the awards
however become the vectors used to
expose nuance in their characters and
help them rediscover their own humanity
there's a moment at the beginning of the
game that was in the e3 demo where
Petraeus shoots the arrow before kratos
expects him to and he starts to yell at
him and then he pauses he takes a breath
and then he calmly but still with a bite
finishes his thoughts only fire
fire when I tell you to fire that was a
big realization moment for us that was
the aha writing or he realized like look
he isn't always gonna be yelling because
always yelling isn't gonna accomplish
something but he's also not really gonna
be able to know how to properly a moat
or be vulnerable or relate to his son so
he's not gonna say a lot right and we
really poke fun at that too we let the
trace have fun with the fact that he
doesn't talk he doesn't like people
right and and I think that lends itself
to this feeling of like there are some
of the most human moments when Kratos is
somewhat quiet I'm sorry do not be sorry
be better while the new god of war is
making a more meaningful attempt at
humanizing Kratos this isn't the first
time Borlaug and his team have attempted
to do this although PSP tayo God of War
Chains of Olympus was primarily still a
story about vengeance it also reunited
Kratos with his door Calliope after
relinquishing his weapons and the powers
he had accumulated Kratos was granted
access into Elysium by Persephone queen
of the underworld there he embraced his
daughter promising never to leave her
again but in a cruel twist Persephone
revealed that she had unleashed Chronos
the Titan to destroy the world including
Elysium in order to stop him and save
Calliope Kratos would once again need to
become the monstrous Ghost of Sparta
breaking the promise to his door however
the gravitas of this moment was undercut
by a QuickTime event in which players
hammered a button to push Calliope away
from him as she pleaded for him to stay
and desperately clung to his legs
it was another instance of vulnerability
for creoles but one that was met with a
mixture of ambivalence and mockery
Kratos had established himself as the
archetypal brute and the sudden pivot to
loving father forced to sacrifice his
own happiness for the sake of others was
criticized for being at best jarring and
at worst an empty attempt at trying to
present him as sympathetic going into
the new god of war borlaug is mindful of
the response to that moment with
Calliope and how the new god of war can
avoid making those mistakes again it
brought me out the response to that one
but it also it
me a really good lesson right you have
to earn the moment right and and perhaps
we didn't do a good job of earning that
moment it doesn't feel natural of
cradles just suddenly is who criticizes
the end of the game right at the
beginning of the game you're like oh
that's abrupt you want to feel like you
have gone on the journey I learned from
those things and say all right I need to
look at this I there's the moment at the
end where Kratos is spoilers carrying
his brother's body up the stairs right
and all of these moments really kind of
go back to Kratos sacrificing his health
spoilers in the end of God War one to
his wife and child right these were
emotional moments that we were trying to
capture with him gameplay and we're kind
of like always looking going where's our
hugging the wife and child moments right
where is that and it's sometimes
successful sometimes not
these are definitely difficult moments
to land if you work hard to earn them
over time they land very well if they
feel shoved in there they feel rushed
they do not work so well earning the
moment in the new god of war means
changing things that fans of the series
have come to expect and based on the few
hours that we've played it seems
developer Sony Santa Monica is more than
willing to do that what stood out in our
play session was how subdued the opening
felt compared to previous titles like
the first game the new God of War opens
on a quiet moment with Kratos chopping
down a tree that holds significance to
his wife and represents taking on the
responsibility of raising their son
properly but unlike the first game which
quickly moved into a battle with a Hydra
on a ship amidst the raging storm it
doesn't immediately escalate into a
bombastic set-piece it gives that moment
space to breathe the time we need to
think about what it meant to Kratos and
how it will impact him going forward
although there was still plenty of
brutal action and an epic boss fight
that unleashed a monster
constantly scratching at the surface of
Kratos his psyche it was the smaller
moments that had the most impact in
these moments you could really feel
Kratos trying to reconcile who he used
to be with who he wants to be and this
is a struggle that Borlaug and his team
are also for
I would say you know the early games we
had that chip on our shoulders is like
we're gonna make a great actually giving
them the even though you say we can it
did fuel me a little bit than when we
announced that a lot of people had that
resistance to it saying like why did
they do this I should have done a new
character or Kratos is just
one-dimensional right it is the same
people who saying he's only
one-dimensional and then you change him
and oh that's terrible why would you do
that I think what's interesting is we
just showed that one part I always use
the comparison saying he's got this
monster inside of him and that monster
was free to run around at all times and
now he has to figure out how to control
it right and let that monster out at set
times and be a little bit more in
control of it and I think that struggle
the fact that he will fail constantly of
that is the interesting aspect of it I
hope that at the end of this we do have
people playing the game and saying I
didn't expect for him to be a character
that had dimension but he is right that
is fantastic I think as a writer as a
director that is a challenge that I love
right because it is hard to create a
brand new character I believe it is
harder to take a character that
everybody thinks they know and
understand and show them a side of that
character that feels sincere that feels
earnest that feels right that is very
different the challenges they're sort of
preconceived notions that's difficult
and if you succeed I hope that we have I
think that is that is a little bit
problem from the idea that problem
within a team
[Music]
so there you have it it was really
interesting chatting to Cory about their
new take on Kratos I'm not gonna lie I
was one of those people who despite
loving the serious thought can you
really make this character interesting
and I was surprised with how I came away
from my short experiences with the game
it seems like they know what they're
doing I'm interested to see whether it
carries on throughout the game but I
have confidence in it now and I didn't
have before so that's exciting in the
meantime if you want something a little
more deeper looking at the combat and
looking at what's changed since the last
few games you can find an analysis video
of all the new mechanics and setup for
the game itself on games become as well
as youtube-dot-com forward-slash
GameSpot while you're there hit the
subscribe button and if you want to let
me know what you think about the old god
of war or the new god of war
you can let me know in the comments or
find me on twitter at two more h-hey
hello let's talk about God of War I love
it you love it let's do it see you next
time